so after a 40o loss to the Clippers you
go to Phoenix you Trail by 20 and you
come back and beat them well I told you
that's that's to me is going to be the
hardest thing from Victor to learn he's
this probably the first time in his life
he's going to lose I guarantee you he's
never lost the game by 40 points I don't
know anything about the French league
but he ain't lost no game by 40 points
but for him to come back be down 20 you
know they they're a young team they're
building for the future they they have
nothing at stake they're not going to
make the playoffs this is a process you
know unfortunately in our business today
we got a lot of gas bags on television
they tell you this guy's a flop this
guy's a flop and I'm like wait a minute
these guys on flops after one year or
two years because you know they're not
like us well they we stayed in school x
amount of years we're drafting kids out
of you know we were going out of high
school or six months in college we need
to take a step back and say yo man
there's no instant success you know this
process yes I mean because I I told you
I've been in NBA for 40 years only one
guy only one guy came in and was great
right away and that was LeBron Kobe
struggled Kevin G Garnett struggled he
struggle you you didn't come right out
of high school fool okay well say that
you just said only one guy came in okay
all right okay don't calm down come down
you were sh you Shack in the beginning
what you w don't do that what don't do
what don't do that don't play me like
that who was he if he wasn't sha then
who was he yeah don't play me like that
I'm want to figure out who he was he was
more clar Kent than Superman okay all
right don't do that check don't do that
Che that check did y'all make the
playoffs your your rookie year no oh
what dam what are you talking about one
game but I had
numbers no I'm just talking about you
didn't dominate like you did I did from
day one yes I did but your point Charles
he ain't got no point he just over there
Jibber ja I got no damn point I got a
point the notion that a guy who's 18 or
19 years old going to come in and
dominate the NBA right away that's just
not going to happen the players are too
good and he's in the Western Conference
other than the Portland Trail blazes who
in a complete rebuild they're not better
than any team in the west yeah I I'd
have to agree with chuck on this point
about patience because the difference
what what what makes a good player a
great player and an average player a
good player is just the decisions so
when you don't have experience like Wim
bayama he's not making he has the skill
set but he doesn't always have the
decision making so right here I'm
shooting shots that are comfortable but
when you when you become these are all
great highlights I I'm talking about at
times when he's not great and I always
thought it it's because of his decisions
that he makes should I post every Gordon
for three more seconds you know what
should I back down the ball two more
seconds that's what LeBron James
understands he understands the rationale
of the game and when things should
happen and then it matches your skill
set because he has an unbelievable skill
set at 7 fo4 and like like I like CH
Chuck said I don't really know anybody
who came into don't believe that that's
I'm leave that though and the only thing
that's really good for him that he has a
coach like Greg papovich the
because usually when you get down by 30
you automatically quit but as Co poic
said they just kept playing and playing
and the things that Kenny mentioned he's
going to have to learn you know he will
be a great player you know it's Chuck
made great point it's different from the
fren French league but you know when you
come in as a rookie you you're just
seeing things and what did you have
things I had to learn how to pass out of
the double team I had to learn how to
play play meter and I had to learn that
finesse was not going to work with me so
that's when I said okay okay the next
year I'm going to turn it up power I got
to take my time and learn like I was
just like moving real quick but I would
learn like if they come from the four
Horus Grant is wide open for the shot
like I was always looking for Penny
always looking for these was just
decision once you see the game so so
once he sees the game he's going to be
fine so you didn't you didn't make the
playoffs your first year no we lost by
one game oh so that 41 but I had I'm
just so the
know but I had better numbers than you
you were you number one pick in the
draft you bigger than me okay but your
dumb just said nobody came in I didn but
you but you you read the cup and shut
up yeah who gave you that Aisha come on
right here who gave you that c be quiet
read the
C I came in I said it the Phoenix teams
two and two over there drinking that Dam
R my wife make a yeah thank you thank
you
chill wait
yeah tell you right now that dessert is
not real oh Nick cilo that is real
brother yep here we go absolutely right
Edward you are
absolutely right when we come back the
highlights from
Cleveland Nicks in the Cavs in game one